but I tell every entrepreneur I try and
get over the next five years 30% of your
sales outside of North America the whole
idea is to diversify your sales risk you
diversify your portfolio if you're just
selling in the US you're gonna be
selling to a economy that's growing at
sub 3% for the rest of your life
so Oprah has a hairdresser interesting
guy he's his hobby was tea this tea new
drink and he became what's called a nose
he had a certain skill to be able to
smell salon teez and blend them one day
he gives couple years ago a cup of tea
to oprah well he's doing her hair and
she sips it and says his bestie I've
ever had she goes on the show a half an
hour later and says this tea called
Talbott teas is the best tea I've ever
had he gets orders the next day for five
hundred thousand dollars you know the
Oprah effect you've heard of it right
he can't finance that so he comes on
Shark Tank and he's looking for $250,000
and I agree to buy 35% of the company
for that I love to you it's so simple
gets on Oprah 500,000 orders and even
Marcus all kinds of individuals ordering
on the internet simple tea orders cash
flow right while we're in the middle of
doing the deal the show airs and Jemma
juice a public company says we want to
be in the tea business we love this
story we love the brand I want to buy
the company I haven't even written a
check yet and bang the deals done Wow
yes wow that's the kind of deal I like
because it was simple it's not a
complicated tech story it's tea tea with
a brand now you go into a Jamba Juice
anywhere in North America
that's my Talbott teas I look at it this
way the simple deals are the ones you
make money on so I take that cash back
Irie deploy it so I like simple stories
with revenue attached to them you know
the high-tech stuff I came out of that
market it's so complicated so much can
go wrong so I just love deals where they
see an easy path to revenue you just
watched two amazing clips from Kevin
O'Leary
take the next three minutes to sit
quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]